richtig krass nein nein
in den ländern in denen der mensch ok
ich hab keinen platz mehr im gesicht man
zuerst geht sondern willkommen zu einem
neuen video
heute habe ich mal wieder eine challenge
für euch jetzt war ich sage nur so viel
sagt wäscheklammern folgendermaßen jedes
mal wenn ich in jump league hier in
dieser runde unterfalle gibt es eine
wäscheklammer für mich in mein gesicht
jedes mal wenn ich aber ein modul
abschließe da habe ich eine wegnehmen
das sind die regeln damit ich auch nicht
allzu sehr leiden muss ich vermisse euch
trotzdem sehr stark werden sehr stark
leiden viel ein star klein naja ok auf
jeden fall habe ich schon mal unser
erstes jedes tier das kader geworfen
ich bin überhaupt nicht eingespielt
leute das kann durchaus und sehr gut
sein dass ich relativ auf darunter
fallen werde
ja wir waren ja gestern abend in götting
leute das war echt cool
heute morgen aus götting zurückgekommen
und werden einfach echte zeit da gestern
richtig cool wie der familie so ein
bisschen immer dabei und noch andere
familienmitglieder okay ich hab schon
zweimal den kies hier geschafft noch
keine wäscheklammer ich würde mache aber
auch ich weiß nicht da kommen wir sagen
wir sagen mal module die man abschließt
oder der wäscheklammer im gesicht zu
haben die die kanten im halben man
rechnen mit einer halben klammer das
heißt ich habe jetzt drei modeblatt
beschlossen also könnte ich mir ein
einhalb klammern aus dem gesicht nehmen
we'll nein nein da kann man nicht im
kessel
okay die erste böse aus war keine
position hier kommt die dazu nötige
kredit schnauze und die kommt erst mal
hier unten hin würde ich sagen es ist
natürlich der konzentration auch nicht
zuträglich das mal so ein scheiß teil
dem gesicht hatte
also ich gehe davon aus dass es nicht
leichter wird mit man solche klamotten
gesicht hat okay wir haben schon 330
euro die kopfhörer
vielleicht klappe es nicht einfach die
kopfhörer festklammern zur heutigen
sprung japan shampoos jedoch gestern
relativ viele lieder gesungen deswegen
bin ich jetzt gerade noch so in diesem
sänger modus das war knapp
und ich muss sagen singen macht mir doch
echt viel spaß
ich wusste dass eigentlich immer schon
aber auch gerade so traditionelle ältere
lieder sowie ja gaudeamus igitur besser
gesungen
das echt voll ich hätte nie gedacht das
klingt ultra spießig aber es macht echt
bock also ich hab wirklich wirklich spaß
am singen was wir das bei euch ist
könnte ja meine kommentare schreiben
während ich versuche mein leid zu
minimieren aber es läuft echt gut
ich bin bisher nur einmal runter
gefallen waren das ist nice oder es aber
eine kritische stelle hier ja ok
und sehr gut ok ich kann jetzt
theoretisch etwas wenn ich jetzt gar
nicht wenn ich so oft gar nicht
runterfallen weil ich jetzt
ausnahmsweise mal konzentriert spielen
dann sage ich einfach kommen wir nehmen
das guthaben raus für absolvierte
checkpoints und sagen erst wenn du eine
klammer gesicht hass und ein checkpoint
maas dafür aus dem ich durfte mir jetzt
die klammer theoretisch wieder abnehmen
aber ich lasse es einfach wie kommst
klammern im face sind nice moment in dem
moment in dem man chapron abschließend
klammer im gesicht hat dürfte man hier
ausleben
ich habe erst mal darauf verzichtet denn
wir wollen ja hier nicht raus brauchst
prosieben schicken audi man sagt im
englischen
jetzt machen wir nicht so aber es läuft
mensch wie es läuft
unfassbar also ich muss mir echt öfters
wäscheklammer ins gesicht klatschen
das scheint mein skills sehr zuträglich
zu sein
oh gott das hier ist aber ein abschnitt
leute den habe ich noch nie geschafft
ich glaube diesen abschnitt geschafft
jetzt wird garantiert eine klammer geben
klammer in your face
ok krass christos karras kaspar knapp
ich weiß nicht wie man den hier nehmen
soll
vielleicht so nein vielleicht so sein
muss jedoch über herausspringen oder
nein
ja ok nice sie so gut gut gut läuft
alles alles gut alles in ordnung
und jetzt hier bitte konzentrieren würde
konzentrieren
nein wahrscheinlich alter schwede okay
nur model du nur du machen sie mal in
die rechte backe damit ihr das seht
junge was jetzt wirds aber richtig geil
ok zeiten klammer ist ja unten drunter
heilige scheiße jetzt gibt's jetzt
wird's hell wie ok eine vierte diesen
besonders liebe diese idee ist ein
richtiger ja wie soll man sagen ich
hatte gerade einen panzer panzers nicht
das richtige wort dafür
wo kommen wir da unten ich lasse mir so
kleinen bord aus rio alto okay ein
bisschen ohrschmuck kann nicht schaden
so ok also es fällt nicht schwer sich
dabei zu konzentrieren sagen alle die
welche gerne wenn erstmal nachempfinden
wollt macht irgendwelche klammern ins
gesicht und versucht dann zu spielen
es ist nicht leicht
dann genau so bösen parcours ok junge
ist schon heute darunter fallen
ich mache ich will nicht unter frei
ich würde sagen es geht aber da hat mich
davon überzeugt dass es doch nicht geht
nein nein muss bisschen seit ich aus
sprich ja sehr schön war jetzt erst
jetzt hat mit ruhe mit ruhe hier drüben
hier drüben sagt ja junge dankeschön ok
welche klar fakt mich am meisten ab die
hier
ich darf eine wegwerf angepackt wo ich
hätte irgendwie wird sich besser obwohl
ihre oscar war wolle nicht stehen
bleiben denn das wäre titelhalter
nikolai und rüstungen einer jung ich
kann einfach komplett man rüstung
wegschmeißen
eine komplette umrüstung in einer kiste
das ist stark das ist stark in asch
alter mann
was von geräuschen beim uefa cup ich
hatte irgendwie ziemlich gerade gehört
okay wir machen auf jeden fall hier ins
rechte auch noch eine rein ja eine
kleine schnapsidee mir gerade gekommen
ist diese ganze geschichte mit der
wäscheklammer challenge aber fragte er
sich und könnte sich die nächste klammer
so es ist auf jeden fall sehr kleidsam
junge ich kann dir gar nicht mehr gerade
sehen irgendwie stören diese
wäscheklammern mein sehvermögen und das
reicht nicht mal im ansatz älter ach ja
ok aber nicht nicht die koffer
herausfand die käuferin junge so 8
sekunden
ich würd sagen wir machen noch
zusätzlich für jeden def im deathmatch
noch eine klasse einfach nur um das
bisschen spannender zu machen
so also nachdem ich jetzt schon ein
bisschen hier am southern bin machen wir
jetzt noch für jeden tod den hier im
deathmatch erleide normaler zusätzliche
klammer aber wir fangen erst gar nicht
an hierfür kältekammern wegzunehmen das
wäre das wäre zu leicht
das wäre zu leicht hat er mich
kribbelt's gerade voll im gesicht
ich glaube die stück drei irgendwas
abayoo ohneis monat ich glaube wirklich
dass mir gerade irgendein teil meines
gesichtes abhanden kommt das stück
kameras pick up down gap da und sagt ich
sehr schön hier wird noch eine idee
gegeben und jetzt möglichst schnell die
runde zu ende bringen möglichst schnell
die runde zu ende bringen dann ist der
ganze käse vorwahl für mich alter junge
ist krieg es kribbelt es nicht wieder
gerade
unfassbar das kribbelt richtig krass
nein nein
ein ewiger nein junge du erbarmungsloser
nutzen auch mensch ok ich hab keinen
platz mehr im gesicht man mein gesicht
ist nicht groß genug also geht es in die
backe er ist es aber ich werde euch zu
jetzt wird's auf jeden fall gerade
stramm was mache ich eigentlich ein käse
falls es irgendwann sieht er mich aus
dem echten leben kennt und sich fragt
warum ich mir gerade wäscheklammer ins
gesicht hänge ich weiß es nicht weiß es
wirklich nicht
ich versuche einfach nur ein paar
menschen zu unterhalten und hoffe dass
wenigstens das klappt weil sonst ist
wirklich also sonst sagt jetzt muss ich
halt umgekehrt und lag noch ein bisschen
mehr dann ist alles gut
ach kommt bisschen irina navaho
wichtiger würde ich mir sage nicht
ja okay man hätte doch falle es ist
schon knackig kalt gerade wenn die auf
dauer so lange drin bleiben ist es
richtig heftig und muss sich
gleichzeitig auf den kampf konzentrieren
und die lippen wenn ich rede wird nicht
so pessimistisch bitte bitte bitte
schnell vorbei machen endlich kann ich
mal reden einfach schnell beenden
dankeschön des alten kinder fisch bauen
welche klamotten trägt schon nicht gut
kommuniziert aber durch naja kommt
alter schwede jung ich alter ist das
knapp gewesen man es ist nicht so schön
man kann nicht mal mehr gescheit
kommentieren wenn man einfach hier so
ein stück mal den día de blob 2 die as
warum weiß keiner
es weiß wirklich keiner verschont werden
aber noch wirst verschont habe ich ein
clown kommt nähe sowie die glaub ich hab
wäscheklammern im gesicht ich kenne sie
kennen kein erbarmen zeigen
dein tod lässt mich schnell die wäsche
draußen gesicht nehmen deswegen verzeiht
mir mein lieber einfach gar nicht retten
konnte ich habe auch noch weiter
chipset jetzt gibt's nämlich auch noch
zu allem überfluss kommt wieder und geht
junge wie alte ich will eben noch hatte
aber ich habe es geschafft die junge und
die fans von selbst ab das sei mir
genehm ich also es wirklich eine heftige
challenge meine haare sind wieder auf
die palme passiert immer mit der zeit
bin ich nicht so heute ja welche folge
gefallen hat mich gequält habe heute das
gerne daumen nach oben da ich nehme
gleich mal die kamera heraus wünsche
euch noch einen schönen tag
haut rein machst du bis zum nächsten
video